so how did this opportunity come about
for you to be on Celebrity Big Brother
well to be honest last year I was
presented with the opportunity to come
on the first season and due to some
contractual obligations that I had I
couldn't do it I was so bombed and then
this year again they asked me and I
basically cleared my schedule seriously
I was like I'm not missing another
opportunity not to be on my favorite
show and so here I am and why is it your
favorite show why is it something you
had to do I've been watching since
season 1 yeah so um it has been my
summertime go to show for what 19
seasons now and so you know it's a big
part of my summertime life and what is
it about the show that just has it you
know is it your your fene what what I
love about the show is that every day is
not the same you go into the house from
what I watch on TV you go into the house
and things are looking one way and then
a couple of hours later a couple of days
later everything has completely flipped
upside down and so it's just the rush of
having to figure out where you're gonna
be who you're gonna be friends with
who's your Alliance now how you gonna go
to the top how you gonna win this
competition cuz you can go inside of the
game thinking you're gonna be you know
laying low I'm gonna be cool but then
find yourself in the midst of all the
drama or causing trouble so we'll see I
don't know how I'm going to be just yet
I just know what I enjoy watching and
how nervous are you about being stuck in
a house with other celebrities oh listen
I'm nurse guided to be stuck in the
house with anyone I have never had a
roommate before yeah don't know how
that's gonna work out on this show but
to be stuck in a house with a bunch of
celebrities
I guess I'm used to it you know my
sister's you know pretty much
celebrities I guess so but that really
doesn't you know faze me at all
what are your sisters think of you being
on Celebrity Big Brother my sisters
think I'm absolutely nuts Tony in
particular she was like you do know
you've never had a roommate and you're
used to doing things your way
I'm never going to miss a
a couple of my sisters know that I
really enjoyed this show my sister
Towanda especially it's one of her
favorite shells too so she's excited for
me because this is something she wants
to do too and we'll see I don't know I
think they think I'm crazy they told me
that doing Christmas break and we'll see
how it all turns out so as you know
there are other celebrities in the house
is there anyone that you would love to
be in the house with you and there
anybody you would hate to be in the
house with you I would love if Mariah
Carey walked through the door I don't
know how much you know conversations you
would get from me or competitions
because I've been all but somebody I
would hate to work I don't know um I
don't I guess somebody who doesn't clean
up after themselves that would annoy me
the most because I'm a neat freak that's
probably not a good thing going into
this house I don't know somebody who
just refuses to clean up and expects
everybody to clean up behind them That's
not me and what is your biggest fear
going into this competition my biggest
fear is not having a good time and not
you know taking every day as it comes
and not living in the moment I don't
want to get so far into the game in my
head that I miss this amazing
opportunity that I have and being a big
Big Brother fan how competitive are you
I'm hardcore competitive fan or not but
because I'm in the Big Brother house I'm
really competitive and I'm ready to win
some competitions and you know when the
regular celebrity the regular
contestants are on this show you know
they're watched in a bubble but they get
to go back to their regular lives when
you're done you go back to being a
celebrity yeah so how worried are you
about what you do what you say
what could happen after you're done with
this show well luckily for me I'm in my
tenth year of doing the Braxtons so I've
used I'm used to the cameras like for
real they're like pieces of art on the
wall or a lamp or whatever I don't even
really pay attention to the cameras
because I am Who I am you know and
whatever kind of day that I'm having
that's the kind of day that I'm having
it's really about how you come back from
that
and a few stars last season they
couldn't handle it and they sent
themselves home what would it take I
know milk I gotta go would there be
anything anything that would be like a
hell no I'm going home if I quit and
when does it go home my family would
never let me live that down so I can
either endure what's gonna happen in
this house or endure was gonna happen
outside of this house forever and ever
and ever so I'm just gonna go ahead on
taking this try and be there until my
time was up and one of the strategies
that some people have our show man says
you know some people have relationships
outside of the house some people are
single how willing would you be to do a
showmance to do what it takes to win
well the funny part about it is that
when I'm in the house I've got my
divorce is gonna be final but I am six
but I am seeing somebody very special to
me and I'm not interested in having a
show man so you're not gonna play me in
front of the whole world honey Oh big
brother no no no uh-uh not I said just
get right on over me yeah and have you
being a fan of you reached out to anyone
to get advice to go into the house I
haven't reached out to any previous Big
Brother celebrity cast members from last
season you know I just felt like I
wanted my own experience and I felt like
if I were to contact somebody and find
out how the house was and what should I
do
was there anything I need to know no I I
don't want to win that way yeah I feel
like that's cheating and I want to beat
you fair and square now let's talk about
the food situation so since you're a fan
you know about slop you know about all
that stuff I do how willing are you to
eat that slopping well here's the thing
I can really really cook very well and
so if I have slop I feel like I could
figure that part out
you know nothing tastes better than
anything deep-fried and so I could
figure that part out in the house I'm
not too worried about you know who's
gonna be cooking who's going to be you
know the person that we go to to eat cuz
I feel like I probably am going to be
that person and you're gonna use it as
your advantage to hopefully let people
keep you around longer you might need to
use that card once or twice and you know
a lot of people use these shows this you
know you've done dancing to help further
their career what do you hope to get out
of this experience I'm not looking at
this shell to further my career you know
thank God I've had an amazing career so
far I'm still young in my career my
career didn't pop off till I was 35
years old and I'm just 41 now and I'm
just really looking to look inside
myself and notice the changes that I
need to make and make those changes
because I've been on a continued path of
living my best life and living your best
life life has everything to do with
knowing exactly who you are and where
you going and I am excited to continue
this journey with the show and if you
win you you get to win that nice prize
money what would you do with that prize
money well I think most of the proceeds
I would contribute it to my charity
which is no need to be shamed calm and
that has everything to do with domestic
sexual abuse I'm a survivor myself and
this is just to help people have an
outlet or somewhere to go when they
don't have a place to go and they don't
have an outlet and the other portion I
think I'm gonna put away from my son's
college fund that's awesome yeah I love
that and what is your strategy for
winning Celebrity Big Brother I think my
strategy for winning or to get as far as
I go
it's just to be myself is to let
everybody know who I truly am and I'm
just not the big loudmouth sister who
gives her unsolicited advice I'm a woman
I'm a good friend I'm smart I know how
to strategize I know how to compete and
I
a good person to have on your side and
you think this will be easier or harder
than Dancing with the Stars really know
this gonna be harder than desert stars
that's what the Stars was all about
being physically and mentally ready I
think this is physically and mentally
ready but I can go home look after
Dancing with the Stars and I can get on
Instagram I get on Twitter I get on
Facebook and I can be with my kid and
around my mom and my loved ones and here
honey
you have to solely rely on yourself so I
think it's going to be harder but I
think it's going to be equally as great
because I did have an amazing time on
Dancing with the Stars and you
unfortunately had to leave Dancing cuz
of your health researcher how are you
doing now I'm doing amazing as a matter
of fact I'm me and Val are still really
good friends I can't wait to go to his
wedding I hope I don't miss it while I'm
in the house and I actually told him he
was going to marry her and he was my
partner and they wasn't even dating I
love it I'm a fun thing you should ask
him oh we will
[Applause]
you